[Music]
so obviously i don't want to spoil
too much of the movie i want you to be
surprised when
when you see it there's something that i
can show you
so i'd like to share a couple of concept
art drawings and it's
barry allen's new suit
[Music]
as you can see it's more organic you can
see
light embedded in it it has been built
by his friend bruce wayne this time
flash fact the first appearance of the
multiverse
in dc comics is actually a flash comic
flash comics number 123 the flash of two
worlds
this film is immensely important because
if you look around at the dc
universe obviously we have all of these
characters that exist
within their own bubbles we even have
now
multiple iterations of the same story
i'm batman and batman i'm batman
sound like a cool guy this movie by
opening that door that flashpoint did in
the comics
all of these stories and characters can
start to collide
um hello
this should be impossible now to be
impossible now
you don't know about the oh my god don't
do this to me i don't know about the
what
the cinematic multiverse is gonna be
born out of this movie it's born out of
barry's story
it blows our minds the levels of
possibility that exist within the
context of this character in this story
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my video for the flash
movie teaser all the stuff they revealed
about michael keaton's batman ben
affleck's batman coming back and what
they're doing with the multiverse so
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing an amazon giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what you want them to do
with michael keaton's batman
and ben affleck's batman during the
movie really hoping they get to share a
scene together they didn't promise that
but there's always the possibility
so i'll just start at the beginning and
number these as we go along just to stay
organized
so number 10 the director andy muschetti
explained that the flash
will get a new suit that's way more
organic as you can see it glows with the
speed force energy arcing across his
body when he's using it
it's going to pop way more on screen and
they're obviously going to tune the way
he runs
just the visual style of the flash just
based on andy muschietti's own personal
taste
he's the director so he kind of gets to
decide how they interpret the flash now
but it'll all be
based on what zack snyder set up so
they're not going to be retconning
anything about the flash
it'll all flow from justice league in
the justice league snyder cut
so we will start the movie in the
justice league suit that he built for
himself with the spaceship parts
there are actually two versions of the
suit that zack snyder built and i
believe that they're going to reference
the second one during the snyder cut at
some point
number nine the flash movie obviously is
based on the flashpoint storyline of
barry going back in time to try and save
his mother but they are changing a lot
of things about that justice league
flashpoint story so it's almost like
it's only flashpoint in name it's not
going to be anything like the flashpoint
movie or the comic book story
but zack snyder revealed recently that
we would see new flash powers quote
unquote during the snyder cut
this is the clip of him talking about
that it was actually patty jenkins of
the wonder woman 1984 movie that asked
him the question to set this up talking
about new flash powers
how do i do this without without giving
too many spoilers
you're gonna see something with flash in
this film i don't think that you've ever
seen before
something that has to do with his
abilities because you know he's a
quantum character he does
he he interacts with time and space so
you might see him do something that is
timely but awesome patty awesome
question and it's awesome to see you
so it clearly seems like zack snyder's
trying to imply that the flash will
perform some level of time travel during
the movie
when he talks about quantum states big
flash comic book powers that we haven't
really seen a lot of yet in the movies
time travel is just the biggest one and
it also helps set up the premise of
flashpoint
so number eight the second big flash
suit that ezra miller has worn was that
future armor suit when he time traveled
during batman v superman
it's just meant to be an upgraded
version of the regular suit with more
armor and a special face plate
this is a much better look at it and
another version of the cyborg suit with
the full armor up
that'll also be in the snyder cut so we
saw him time travel during the nightmare
scene
and in the justice league snyder cut
trailer recently there was a way bigger
version of that scene playing out with
the ruins of the hall of justice and a
better look at what happens if they
don't save superman from dark side in
the anti-life equation
all that will flow into the beginning of
the flash movie
so number seven we found out that ben
affleck is coming back with a flash
movie as bruce wayne it was actually
one of the biggest news stories last
week that just implies he's not going to
be wearing his batman costume or
anything in the movie he'll just be in
his
street clothes during the scenes as
bruce wayne but there are a couple
really important reasons
why they're bringing him back for the
movie they said that they sent him the
script like just a couple days before
they dropped the news and ben affleck
said yes after reading the pages
they said he's a core part of the story
the emotional through line because
not only does he understand what the
flash is going through they both lost
their mothers when they were children
even though there's not going to be any
kind of martha scene or anything like
that there have been memes about that
since they announced it
but the next major reason practically is
because he's also going to build
this new flash suit that they showed off
canonically he's been a mentor to the
flash this whole time but he's sort of
passing the reigns that to michael
keaton's batman who will become the new
mentor to the flash
based on the teaser that they released
in the story they explained it sounds
like he builds that new suit for the
flash before he travels the multiverse
to meet michael keaton's batman on his
earth
but number six the last reason obviously
they're bringing him back is to give ben
affleck's batman a proper
bookend as batman because even though he
will be back as batman and the justice
league snyder cut next year he formally
stopped being batman when matt reeves
took over to do the batman movie with
robert pattinson
i know there's still a lot of questions
about what the future is for his
character
inside the larger connected dceu
universe and would we ever see him in a
justice league movie i'll address that
later in the video
there have been all kinds of rumors
about ben affleck the last couple of
months
since we found out about the snyder cut
but they're not gonna retcon him out of
the cannon he's still technically going
to be the batman
of this version of earth that the
justice league is from but there aren't
any big plans for him to start
showing up in a bunch of other dc movies
besides the flash movie
so number five there was also some
claims recently i saw that reverse flash
isn't going to be the main villain of
the flash movie which sounds kind of
weird because he's the main villain of
the flashpoint storyline that they're
adapting
it's always possible it's still just a
rumor right now but the story that
they're doing
isn't close to the comic book flashpoint
and they didn't have any michael keaton
batman stuff going on during justice
league flashpoint
so it's always possible that they find
someone else like there's not going to
be thomas wayne batman
or other larger justice league war
aquaman wonder woman stuff going on
during the movie
i'm still assuming that they'll at least
introduce reverse flash even if he isn't
the main villain he's just too big of a
character in the flash comics to skip
out on completely
worst case scenario they pull a joker
dark knight situation
and they just tease him at the end of
the first movie and set him up as the
main villain of the second movie
i know everyone's been posting the fan
art of anthony starr from the boys as
reverse flash he would make a perfect
reverse flash
plays a perfect psychopath very similar
personality to reverse flash
but number four even bigger the dc
multiverse teaser so during that teaser
montage they talk about connecting
to a bunch of different dc movies
through the flash movie
like him traveling the multiverse to
connect to christopher reeves superman
the classic wonder woman series they
even have footage of keanu reeves
constantine
in dr manhattan from the watchmen movie
technically watchmen
is part of the dc universe as of the
events of the button storyline in
doomsday clock
there was also a watchman easter egg
during crisis on infinite earths when
they went to lucifer's earth earth 666
because he's the devil
the button storyline was also a big
batman flash crossover story as well
but i don't know necessarily that means
we'll see full-blown versions of those
characters appear
briefly during the flash movie or if
they'll pull something similar to what
the flash tv show did when grant
gustin's flash traveled to earth 2 or
during crisis on infinite earths in that
big post-credits scene
during the flash tv show when he travels
to another earth you just get a montage
of scenes from a bunch of other tv shows
including the 90s
flash tv show with john wesley's ship is
that version of barry allen they later
paid that off and actually brought his
character onto the show making it canon
so my assumption is is they'll do
something similar to the montage when he
travels the multiverse he'll just get
glimpses
of these other movie universes quote
unquote like the christopher reeve
superman they're not gonna bring him
back for the movie they'll probably just
reference his superman in some way
but number three because you're all
asking obviously the grant gustin
justice league crossover
scene from crisis on infinite earths
they included a big scene from that
implying that they also plan on
connecting with the tv shows from their
side of the movie things
you could say after watching that that
the tv shows are canon to the dc eu now
but in order to
make it a real thing the movies have to
acknowledge it from their side too
they didn't spoil whether or not grant
gustin would film new scenes for the
flash movie but the flash tv show runner
in a separate panel said that he did
want to do more movie crossovers so he's
willing to let grant gustin take a day
or two off to go film scenes for the
flash movie
also on the promise that they would get
to do some more cameos on the tv show
with
other movie actors like cyborg in
particular he mentioned
so number two even though they're not
gonna do the big wonder woman aquaman
war from flashpoint they do talk about
crossing over with wonder woman how
they'd like to do that in the sequels
and then ezra miller talks about meeting
nicholas cage inside the movies
not the nicholas cage version of
superman that never was
but nicolas cage himself the actor so i
wouldn't be surprised if they actually
did
something like that even if it's not
nicholas cage it's some other person
it just sounds like they're going to be
doing so much with the multiverse during
the movie
michael keaton's batman is just the
beginning of that so number one
the michael keaton batman story they
didn't reveal the reason why he gets so
fully involved in the story but during
that teaser you actually see them
on his earth getting ready to fight a
bunch of thugs he's in his classic 1989
batman suit but there was some talk
that he might actually be wearing the
kingdom come harness suit so he might
get some upgrades that original 1989
suit for the movie
he's got a few city miles on him it'd be
weird if batman were wearing the exact
same costume
i know there's a lot of questions about
his future in the dc movie universe the
live-action batman beyond movie that it
sounds like they're making
there was a lot of comments on the
robert pattinson batman trailer that it
looked kind of like a batman beyond
movie because of the red logo the way
that came in
and because of the fact that robert
pattinson's batman resembles terry
mcginnis with his haircut and his look
but once they start filming we get some
more details about the flash movie i'll
do some new videos just everyone let me
know in the comments what you're most
hyped up to see in the movie
while you wait for everything click here
to watch the batman trailer a billion
more times and click here for the black
atom trailer and all the other dc fan
dome trailers
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you